[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship
july 29 moment house dot com slash tiny
meat gang
tell them what we're doing we're doing
it's gonna be so much fun we got dj's
head from spock
we got a live that's cringe we're doing
a new cody noel do we're premiering it
no one's ever seen it we learned how to
sword fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and
we got some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for
24 hours after the show happens so in
case you bought a ticket but you miss it
you can still watch it for the day after
but after that
this finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.comgang
anyways man um i think it's time
that we get busy with the thing that
everyone's been one
it's time to play love island love
island season three with codell
with codelrov let's get into it um
yeah i'm excited too joey chestnut ate
76 hot dogs
that's right oh sorry michelle
[Laughter]
sorry this
completely threw me off
[Laughter]
let's open the ship all right ladies and
gentlemen
let's do this starting off the game
uh we all know this part your heels
click on the driveway
it's it's dope we know this yeah it's
cool let's just motor through
ella dean ella dean wait aladine
paladin's nuts
all right 135 she's from cardiff she's a
glassblower
she makes like bongs she smokes that's
sick
heard every blowing joke 100 times
already
that's [ __ ] turning us on already
um we're gonna compliment wow i love
your outfit yeah yeah we gotta
we gotta flirt that's usually our
technique it usually works
yeah gone straight to it straight to it
i love your milk wagons
you just keep going i've been feeling
well nervous yeah we know
we're nervous too being around that
naked ass body
uh we're nervous just kind of hungry i
think yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah wait no i gotta grow
up dude i'm [ __ ]
eight years old nah it's fine how am i
feeling
kind of hungry kind of hungry for sure
you mean like hungry for love or
something something something i like
dairy
feeling more like cheesecake sounds like
you need a snack
right in front of me yeah oh yeah ella
dinan on those
jugs let's go i've never heard that one
before
ella dying in these nipples
[Laughter]
all right moving on we gotta rename our
character to ella
yeah all right now we get the second
girl
so we're straight to the bedroom
straight too easy to the bedroom her jaw
drops when you walk in
what's up aj
are you the new arrival yeah we are uh
man i knew everyone is going to be
gorgeous but i wasn't prepared
we are pretty [ __ ] like slamming dude
brown skin crazy ass hair oh yeah dope
ass bikini
yeah and we come in with this half naked
glass blower yeah what's up aj you
[ __ ] dweeb you ready to eat some box
ups is here
jesus christ
i'm saying dude this season we're
dominating we're not even meeting the
guys yeah
no we're all the guys gonna walk hello
i'm shut the [ __ ] up man
i don't i don't care i don't care i
don't care
you know you know steven shut the [ __ ]
up
i don't give a [ __ ]
do you introduce yourself to stephen or
hit his hand hit his hand away
all right let's motor through we know aj
let's get up to her first hold on the
best part can i can i just say something
about the show again yeah yeah real fast
yeah
when chugs every time he was like
chatting with a girl and she was like
what's your type
and he's like the very first thing he
said it was all personality matters the
most
yeah but after that i like little
blondes and then he's talking to chloe
who is exactly his type she's like
what's your type and he goes you yeah
it's like what happened to the
personality part dude leave that she's
got it
it's just gone all right real quick
uh we gotta meet aj she's 21 she's
taking a bath that's great
she's a pro hockey player knows how to
handle a stick
that's great it's great yeah because she
can stick this strap on
sorry jesus all right
so we got aj she's like the sporty one
whatever
bro am i tripping is that never mind
i thought i saw something in the in the
shading aj's here to have fun not get
into drama uh me too let's keep it chill
there's no fun without drama um i don't
care
i don't care as long as i get what i
want yep yep hit it
i don't care i don't set out to create
john but i will if i have to
um it's not called friend island yeah
[Laughter]
it's called milk island
fair play to air all right motor through
this [ __ ]
my friendship is i don't care we're on
our hot guys
no we're on our hot girl [ __ ] yeah so
we're not
getting to know anyone yeah we just want
to [ __ ]
exactly what's my career back home model
scientist musician or athlete [ __ ]
scientist i'm gonna do all the above on
that
let's be a scientist be a scientist
that's such a
weird oh wow that's really cool yeah
it's cool that i'm
a nerd like you but hot you have dairy
scientists
i like how i called her a nerd but she's
a hockey player
all right suddenly you hear beeping
noise
sounds like a text oh i've too you
[ __ ]
think ella dean this is the show with
cell phones stupid you're gonna get a
text
act like you've been here ella dean not
reading that someone else read that too
hot
all right we got to meet the boys now
walk out as the girl what boys [ __ ]
gay
all right so this is important to
establish to to everybody my type is
uh big ass jugs
uh my type is big cans and box
i like whole foods smart and mature
no smart mature funny and cute whatever
it is as long as they're hot
whatever yeah whatever as long as
they're hot three abrasive
dude they didn't sleep this time as
always
there's a box of condoms on a nearby
table oh let's go
that's not a thing in the real show
though it's not they don't really
promote
sex having that much nah because they
just go raw
as they promote raw talking that's what
it is
they just have boxes of birth control
everywhere and
now they have boxes of condoms but
they're all empty oh yeah true
you open it's like psych get on get an
iud
all right moving on am i going to need
the condoms i'm not planning to have sex
in here i'll take one now
grab a whole hand travel whole handful
let's go dude we don't play games in
here
trick or treat am i right
i can take as many as i want
[Laughter]
you take a fistful of condoms then flush
them down the toilet
you come back in the room and proudly
exclaim i will be getting pregnant
this season that's my goal
that's my goal i came here to be a
mother
all right these beds are really comfy
perfect for doing bits yeah perfect for
doing
what kind of bits are you doing oh my
yes and
yes and oh mate these beds are so comfy
and
she gets on top
do you know what they say about brexit
what do they say
it's not that good without syrup
i don't breakfast brexit i'll keep
working on that one
lucky working on that one yeah that one
didn't really hit for me
your phone beeps wait is it my turn
already
yeah kodo come down to the lawn and
couple up the boys are waiting
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah i mean we don't really
want i mean it depends we could just
play it
we're just picking let's play the entire
field yeah
no i mean we're no we're we're playing
we're playing them
yeah we're [ __ ] them up yeah we're
just breaking hearts
on the boys side but with the ladies
we're going to work we're falling in
love yeah
we are playing the field okay but the
boys are getting played in two ways
okay already hate this dude eat this guy
dude
i don't want to know anything about him
i don't want to know
don't say anything the first boy steps
forward with a cheeky so i don't give a
[ __ ]
i don't care what kind of smile he's got
on it i don't give a [ __ ] get him
out of here shut up shut up i hate your
voice
no it's just that oh god it's just i'm
from
i'm from oxford i'm from oxford i don't
care don't care
not attracted bill
bill yeah you look like bill bill the
[ __ ]
bill bill bill bill bill nye the not
getting [ __ ] guy
dude this guy sucks why are you standing
like that
oh my god with
his knees go backwards no that's what
he's doing
bill take your razor scooter back to
surrey and fill another hole in a roof
strong opinions about sandwiches
shut the [ __ ] up man how about a knuckle
sandwich
don't even pause for this dude i don't
know anything about him
no bill says i'm a bit of him roll your
eyes roll your eyes
[ __ ] off you
his face falls good
he dies his face falls off and your trip
starts to kick in
you see jesus and the whole island is
fake
[Laughter]
you're just on acid a bill never existed
it's not real all right you look at this
your worst fear manifested in front of
you
you look down to the next boy all right
all right
hola chica welcome to the villa amazing
isn't it
yeah amazing how there's not more girls
here
oh yeah whatever is it is it
well it is now you're here why is he
like shouting
his face coming hello yeah
from rumford shot black button grafton
embroidery nice cool good little joke he
could fight he's good
he's good you can fight all right roll
up bill
[Laughter]
put him on his back and fold him beat
the [ __ ] out of him
put us all out of our misery right yeah
choke him out all right
go ahead let's just let's let's go
straight to the bts member
that's just what it's saying is that
jimin yeah
uh camilla definitely likes me uh too
early to say
it's too early to say that we don't want
to [ __ ] with any of the guys
the third and final boy in the line
seems nervous oh my god dude
[Music]
hi i'm 16 trying to pop out his chest a
little bit
hey i'm harry i'm someone's little
brother
he's from york 21 jesus usually wears a
tie with his swimsuit
he's a dork cool we can bully this is
great
for what it's worth i'm just as
gobsmacked as he's a zero game
no game wait who says gobsmacked no one
i've never that's what i'm saying i
haven't heard that
you never say that especially not in
that's like a
flirting situation i think you read like
gobsmacked in like a
like a you know some ninth grade reading
assignment yeah what does that even mean
gobsmacked uh is it god smacked or gobbs
gob smacked i think harry is trying to
flirt with me too
uh bless his heart the meanest thing we
can say yeah it's not working bless your
heart
alright so these are the options for now
they all seem keen
it's so tough to pick a boy more boys
are coming later or whatever
um keep smashing
who should we couple up with i i'm
saying harry cause we could punk his ass
okay i was gonna say bill just so we can
hate him
didn't we do that kind of like that too
yeah yeah we did that with one another
like red-headed dude yeah yeah
yeah we bullied the [ __ ] out of him we
should bully bill
we could bully bill or harry either or
but he feels like a little mean with
harry feels like you're pulling a kid
that's what i mean yeah let's bully bill
yeah
couple up with bill it's great because
we rolled our eyes at him
you're so hard to reach shut up shut
up god i'm not sure if the child is it's
not
it's not don't [ __ ] talk too much
and by the way you're you're on the
couch tonight i'm taking to bed
[Laughter]
you stride over to bill what's up dork
you can barely he can hardly believe his
luck yeah you're not lucky dude
codell stop doing that i thought that
you were hydrated
nice one nice one as he winks me and
bill are officially coupled up hands off
for now
hands off forever yeah
i kind of feel bad for him man no it's
just there's no sympathy
i don't understand this girl is giving
me mixed signals he said
i'm so glad you picked me shut the [ __ ]
up
here's the best part because we're
paying to play this game
we're never going to get voted off so we
can be mean to everyone yeah that's true
hey girl congratulations wait who are
these dudes
that's her dude you really bagged
yourself a hottie over here we got
another russ
top right yeah that's me after yoga
[Laughter]
oh man all right so we got nikki cool
smash through this hi by the way
uh what's up man new islander nikki
well what are we already coupled up why
are they introducing i guess this
happens
yeah yeah music tutor
does that what does that mean let me let
me teach you how to play the flute
are you gonna fart while you do it
uh-oh everyone will pinch their nose got
a music tutor over here play us
something with your ass
all right we got russ this [ __ ] i
think he's adjusting a ring
man i hate that he's adjusting a ring
bro yeah this guy's on tick tock for
sure yeah seb too oh
sebastian name's seb this fool is in
venice right now
yeah yeah i was in the island game okay
owns 52 t-shirts and one shirt sweet man
sick dude 28 is from liverpool he runs a
music shop music shop
cool yeah i'm not even from liverpool
actually i'm from orange county
i studied abroad one semester and i'm
like i totally fit in here
i'm brash i love beer i completely lost
my accent too when i was there
it's nuts place slaps honestly
all right moving on so aj's with uh russ
cool um
ella dean is with nikki we're with bill
what else we got uh what is this
you can't date nicki or seb in this
season of the love island game that
doesn't mean you can't be friends and
don't worry all the other boys and some
of the girls are options what the [ __ ]
why would they tell us i don't know
that's weird that's cool
seb had no chance with us anyway i think
they probably like
just lost a little bit of budget for the
writers oh yeah
they just had like one guy and he's like
i don't want to do all these story lines
dude they're like uh
look at this [ __ ] tree of like
possible [ __ ] like right right right
we'll just kill off top half
what's so funny it's like who are the
least likable characters
probably seven nikki yeah low
probability coupling yeah
it's actually a hilarious insight or
stat for them probably is that there are
characters that no one gives a [ __ ]
about
yeah all right moving on that's cool we
weren't gonna bang anyway
um so what do we think about the last
two girls because we haven't met them
yet
i can't wait to meet them they better
stay away from bill they get as close to
bill as they want
maybe they got lost on the way here i
can't wait to meet him we definitely
want to meet these ladies it's actually
funnier if we like
fight for bill so like we let the other
girls know like he's ours
and then we give him nothing yeah but he
gets no chance at anyone i think that's
called abuse
yeah that's [ __ ] up yeah i think
that's the beauty that's pretty sadistic
yeah
yeah so he has he has autonomy but as
far as like
the capacity for us to like him yeah
never fair fair you know what's funny
though
is what we're describing right now is
some people's version of flirting
yeah you're so [ __ ] annoying yeah god
i want him
the chat is so good so good so good bill
if you speak again i will leave the show
god she's got
butter that's crazy
harry says i'm straight trying to look
confident but then immediately caves
from his
crippling anxiety being the one with the
smallest
sinks back down into reddit posture
being with one of the smallest wrists in
the villa he's afraid to offer to lift
anything
okay so here we are we're getting to
know everybody everyone's
yep yapping here and there do dreams
come true in the villa
nikki um our dreams are just too weird
my dreams are too weird
you don't even know my dreams i almost
got stabbed last night yeah
i'm on acid right now i'm freaking out
hit that [ __ ]
if they manage to make my dreams come
true oh
i'll be impressed well look we'll find
out if any of these people make our
dreams come true in the next episode
um of love island because at this point
all right
we're we're gonna kick it off we're
coupled up with bill
and uh we have all the couples there
so going forward um kyle is gonna assist
us in motivating some of the story and
we'll recap parts of it
and we'll play so this time this way we
can get to the [ __ ] end
this series is all about getting to the
bags i like that
this is it's crazy how we're just
being the most toxic dude but we're not
because we're a girl
exactly toxic femininity yeah yeah
toxic lesbianity yeah if that even is
real